and that was one of the biggest lessons
that i've ever learned but
luckily for me that wasn't the first
time that that happened to me i'm in a
fraternity
so i remember me and my uh fraternity
went to indianapolis to step in the
circle city classic
and we had this theme where we was like
oh man we had these goofy wigs and
suspenders and all that
and this was a step show in a arena like
it was in an arena
and i'm talking about we got no love
it was so bad that the people who came
from our school was scared to even clap
because they didn't want nobody to know
we was with them
so it humbled me once i got off stage
that time like
oh no this ain't the thing that's just
going
you got to work bro you have to work you
got to really work and from that moment
on
i've worked and
luckily in that work i already had the
establishment
i don't care about what nobody thinks
about me give a [ __ ] what you think
about me you can think whatever you want
to think about me
it's on you god bless you but
i'm going to work and even if you don't
appreciate what i do or don't like what
i do
you're gonna have to respect the fact
that he doing it
and that's the part that has always kept
me
in my own pocket you know i mean and
being able to be comfortable on stage
and being honest on stage because
i don't care about what you think about
the things that i love you know i mean i
know
the people who love me unconditionally
and i make sure that i do everything in
my power to make sure that it stays that
way
everybody else is just somebody who is
formulating an opinion based off what i
do
and you're entitled to that and i'm
gonna continue to do what i do
and you can continue to formulate the
opinions that you choose to formulate
around it but
i'm gonna work work that's what it's
about man we made it this is what
this is this is what it's about right
here like i like how
how unique is it to be drinking some hot
breath water [ __ ] this
probably tastes like slob it's fontes
water
but it's very good georgia georgia
mountain spring water georgia mountains
spontaneous mountain spring water listen
you got to be from some ville
to be able to find your own spring
that's what i'm saying man gotta listen
craig we ain't got enough white people
man
we gotta get some white people yo i'm
the plug he's the plug
he got a spring most [ __ ] got hookups
on
you know [ __ ] rims and [ __ ] like that
he got a hook up on a spring hey man
come on down to someville we got a
spring that you can go down there and
bother you some water up
i got water and whites so whatever y'all
need that's what it is
hey man we with you man i appreciate
this is cool man i appreciate you for
having me on here i appreciate you being
on here man and we've been we've been
chipping away at the 85 south gang we've
just got dc left oh yeah that's gonna be
a good one man you know
that's gonna be good like that's
definitely gonna be a good one man uh
you know but this is these type of
conversations are necessary and
you know if i can be any uh motivation
to anyone who's out here trying to
pursue
this as a career or pursue this as a
dream my biggest advice would be
block out the [ __ ] man whatever you
consider the [ __ ] to be block it out
figure out
how you can block it out and then once
you block it out
start walking and keep on walking
hey hot brother and sister if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch
more videos to get even more comedy tips